do you feel like you're kind of like a
helping kick down the door for like you
know because we would always I mean
you've talked about it but just like
Indians and entertainment would always
be at least in the US obviously the
Indian movie space is wild it's like its
own world but like in terms of like U.S
casting it's always like super
typecasted [ __ ] but I feel like that's
been coming like a lot less like like
I think in general with just most races
that aren't white or black like yeah
um it's opening up a lot more but I
think on the comedy side like I think
like you kind of a really like faced a
lot of those like stereotypes or a lot
of those like conceptions about your
people in the entertainment industry
head-on do you feel like you're kind of
helping kind of change that narrative a
bit in a way now I always had a
different take on like I got a lot of
those stereotypical or whatever but I
always had a different take on what's
offensive to me and what's not right
most people and I think a lot of times
people kind of and this is what bring
back a pool is also kind of fighting
back against I think is a lot of
minorities will take white people's
guilt about what has been done in the
past which is [ __ ] but they will
really exploit that and Hammer that home
and the point of their comedy is to make
them feel bad and that was a way to like
elevate your own profile and get your
money those guys don't often really help
out Indians or brown people there's one
Entertainer I see who's really doing it
you know Rami Yusuf right yeah that
[ __ ] is about it dude his his
show is not about guilting anybody and
then he puts all his homies on he's
doing a show for Mo armor Mo yeah that's
Rami that helped get that done it's a
great show if you are brown and talented
Romney will do what he can to elevate
you and I feel like that's the way to do
it I think what a lot of we see is like
um oh I get Typecast as you know accents
and then they just do that to get ahead
yeah and the other thing too was like yo
why is like a boo is like a he's like
obviously like a he's a business owner
yeah you know what I'm saying he's got a
family yeah there's great things yeah
about that character now was he voiced
by a white guy sure yeah and if you
wanted to if this if it was hey just
have an Indian dude do the voice cool
but it wasn't that it was a lot of oh my
God look at the struggle we go through
and it's not fun to get made fun of
would be a poo accent but like you can't
possibly compare that to what black
people have been through in America
which gay people have been through in
America you're doing this to get ahead I
just know for a fact you are none of you
got PTSD from this [ __ ] and if there may
be a couple of you most you don't got
PTSD from this right like it's not a
thing right it's not stop it and I hope
what I see a lot of minorities do to get
ahead is kind of take the liberal side
of everything right and I'm not
conservative I do think I'm very
moderate I think nowadays man
I traditionally am a liberal guy yeah
but I swear the last three years hasn't
made me like just pulled me to the
Middle where I'm just like I don't know
100 everybody's batshit crazy 100 and we
should be allowed to say that without uh
upsetting and still get opportunities it
should be okay to say that and I do
think I'm it's before it was either you
know you are the liberal guy and I'm not
picking on him but Aziz was doing a lot
of that before yeah a lot of it dude a
lot he was they called him woke Bay yeah
even like his last stand up I got like
five minutes in and I was like all right
it was a lot of like you started really
lean in that way yeah rewarded for it or
you'd got to do the Candace Owens thing
which is also it's even worse it's
insane it's gross but you can't just be
like a moderate guy who's like yo both
y'all are [ __ ] crazy as a minority
felt like you couldn't do that and I
hope that's what I can do yeah it's okay
to push back on either side I think
that's what as during the pandemic I
think that was also a great thing that
you guys provided was just like
unadulterated like non-partisan
just [ __ ] both sides we have to offend
everybody I feel that [ __ ] both sides
yeah it's like this [ __ ] is crazy none
of this [ __ ] makes sense like I think I
think like and even like certain [ __ ]
like the like you know um when you guys
had that uh what's what's the comedian's
name from La who said he was into the
trans women and you guys they're posting
that's my guy dude you guys brought the
girl on the next episode that [ __ ] is
hilarious but it's also like Ultra
Progressive if you really think of like
bringing somebody from that community on
in a normal situation yeah it kind of
like you know I think we we only see
those kind of people in like memes yeah
or like in like this like really
extremely like weird woke way and like I
just thought it was like the best way to
normalize any group of people or any
person is to treat them normally and
just talk to them talk to them normally
it's a special point right so if we have
a conversation with a trans woman and
then we make some jokes but we have fun
and we learn and you're gonna make a
joke with a straight woman you're gonna
make a joke with everybody that's what
you're going to do oh yeah that's what
it is equal opportunity offenders and
then I feel like hey now I think a lot
of people walked away from that like oh
I look at this differently yeah for sure
yeah for sure